Film Courage: …On this same event [referenced
in another video] that had this panel of crime
writers, they were fascinating and talking
about different things and when asked they
said the thing feared most because they write
about crime and some of their descriptions
are gruesome, what do they fear most?
The biggest fear was that the well is dry
for ideas.
I thought this was interesting.
Orson Oblowitz, Filmmaker/Photographer: The
well is dry for ideas.
Film Courage: Does this ever scare you?
Orson: Yes, all the time.
I think that we all deal with trying to tell
a unique story.
It’s so funny, it actually goes back to…and
I keep using people’s quotes but I was reading
in an interview that Francis Ford Coppola
did last week and he’s 80 years old.
He’s trying to make a big movie and they
asked him what makes an artist as a filmmaker?
Do you have any advice to young entrepreneurial
filmmakers or artists.
He goes well if you want to be an entrepreneurial
that’s one thing.
But he goes if you want to be an artist as
a filmmaker just start off with the one thesis
which is this: there is a one in a trillion
chance that this zygote was created that created
this single individual (yourself or any of
the other 10 billion people on this earth).
Understand that everyone has an extremely
individual story no matter who they are and
you can be an artist.
And I think that goes back to the well will
never be dry because every story is individual.
Every story is specific.
And I think as a filmmaker you just have to
go out and fight to find that story, it’s
not always going to come to you.
But there’s always a story, there’s always
an experience, there’s always a history
that someone or something has and it’s your
responsibility as a storyteller to go find
it and manicure it and help it grow as if
it was a flower or garden until it finally
comes to fruition.
Film Courage: Which would you say you want
to be?
An artist or an entrepreneurial filmmaker?
Because it seems like the days of the artists,
you almost can’t just be that?
Orson: I mean I’d love to just be an artist
walking around with a camera and thinking
but we all have to pay rent.
But in the end I don’t know I never thought
of myself trying to be like an entrepreneur
or trying to reinvent the wheel.
I just want to tell stories and I hope that
those stories resonate with some people and
if along the way you happen to be successful
in business, that’s amazing.
We all want it.
We all want a more comfortable life than we
have at the moment.
I think even the richest people are always
looking to make their life more comfortable,
make their life better.
Whatever those reasons are.
But I think Queen [referring to Orson’s
film THE QUEEN OF HOLLYWOOD BLVD.] and the
other two films, I think I have a predilection
I like focusing on people who don’t necessarily
have their stories told not as if I’m not
going to go to the homeless guy on the street
and be like “I’m going to tell your story.”
Maybe one day but I’m not saying it has
to be extremes all the time.
But I like telling stories about people in
their small worlds and showing that everyone’s
world is really important to them and everyone
has their own individual evolution so I don’t
know I guess I want to be an artist and I
guess I’d love to be an artist (consider
myself an artist) but I think it’s a business
and we’ve all got to do business as well.
Film Courage: How do you start a screenplay.
I mean since you love character that aren’t
mainstream and I am the same way.
I don’t resonate with a lot of “chick
flicks” and it’s not that…to me I can’t
identify with it.
It’s too perfect for me.
I find myself getting squeamish.
I like something with more edges around it.
Orson: Yes, I like broken people because I
feel like one as well.
I like people who are conflicted.
It’s so weird…how do I start a screenplay?
All different ways.
I can’t tell you.
The biggest part of the process it’s the
dumbest thing in the world - the empty page
is the scariest thing in the world so it’s
just like the way I start writing is say I’m
a photographer as well so most of my films
that I’ve written are based off of an image
maybe that I’ve taken.
That’s kind of where I start a lot is someone
who I have captured through an image either
the image really ends up having nothing to
do with the story.
It’s kind of like there’s an image burned
into my head and I start with that and I allow
that to take its evolution.
I’m a pretty sloppy writer in that I just
start writing and I let the story and the
characters guide me because I mainly write
films that are seen by a singular POV of the
main character.
So because of that I kind of follow that character
and I learn about them and as I learn about
them a plot evolves.
But that’s kind of how I start on a film
I’m writing it from the beginning is it
mostly comes from an image and then that image
mostly gives me an idea for a character and
then I follow that character and then that
world starts to build and then I rewrite a
lot.
Sometimes it will come, someone goes “Hey
I might have some money to make a movie.
I have a small idea, what do you think?”
And that idea because a giant kernel or it
becomes a kernel that pops and suddenly you
run with that idea because there’s a real
possibility of making it and you make it your
own.
I mean that’s a big thing I’ve learned
about filmmaking is you’ve got to be able
to sometimes make someone else’s idea your
own and that’s a really interesting process
as well in its own right.
But for writing with me its the image comes
first and then the character and then I follow
that character and I find a world and I find
a plot within that character’s world and
I go on the ride.
I try to be the first audience member and
enjoy that process.
I like to write fast and this could also be
to my own detriment but I don’t spend a
lot of time on a screenplay.
I try to just write fast, get it out and push
it out there and then start going through
the rewriting process.
I show it to a group of people that I trust
or attach some how to the project but mainly
you always need a good sounding board and
it’s one of the most important elements
of the writing process (of every process of
the film) is having people that you can go
“What do you think because I’m lost?”
And finding that nature of people that can
give you notes and ideas and tell you when
you’re right or wrong or too stuck.
Film Courage: With [The Queen of Hollywood
Blvd.] was there an image?
I know you said you were in a conflicted place
when you wrote it but was there an image [that
prompted it]?
Orson: Yes, there was a photo of a woman on
Western Avenue wearing a leopard skin coat
that I took out of the side of a car and the
film started with an idea of a woman in a
leopard skin coat.
Film Courage: Was she waiting for a bus?
What was she doing?
Orson: I’m not sure what she was doing,
it was probably not good.
Film Courage: Okay…she wasn’t waiting
for an Uber.
Orson: She had seen better days.
But it was cool I know the image.
I can see it in my head right now and it’s
actually funny enough now next to where I
took the image was in front of a church which
is now next door to my office where I write
and edit and stuff.
So years later…
Film Courage: Oh wow, how ironic?
That is really interesting.
Orson: Yes it is, I was thinking about it.
But I remember that image and from that image…that
image just spurned this character and then
the character I pulled from my life and tons
of real-life situations and scenarios and
people and then other photos I had taken.
I wrote about those characters and then some
of them changed on set…everything.
The whole writing process is such an evolution.
But yes, it really did come from a photo out
of the side of a car.
Film Courage: On Western Avenue in Hollywood?
Orson: On Western Avenue, yes.